[Music]
you have a great sense of humor you're a
big fan of the photo bomb and that's
something you bring a lot of joy i think
to other players certainly fans it's
really fun to watch you we have a
picture of you with chris paul i think
there you are
[Applause]
that's the same look that's the same
look elijah's giving when he's on the
runway
we got you with dwyane wade i love this
one
[Applause]
those are really good
and then i like this one a lot because
this is actually an action shot lebron's
talking on camera in this videotape and
you it's fun
we know it's going to be a hostile crowd
with cb jumping
[Applause]
for it yeah i look forward too it's
funny you know being on the team that
actually wins is is really fun and uh
really that's so shocking to me i know
it is i've always wanted to be on the
losing team
it seems it could be more drama there
yeah i'm not a dramatic person no no no
no but uh just actually um being in that
position to win games and your mind just
starts wondering after a while and i
love the cameras so yes you do yeah when
i see it i'm like what would be funny
right now if i'm on the court
i'm like how can i mess with this dude i
wasn't gonna show this one but i have to
show it it's you doing the robot this
might i love this one
[Applause]
good
too
you know what you should start doing is
you should start doing that stuff during
the game while you're playing
do what i mean you hit a shot and then
like duck out and then come back in
again and look around as long as we're
winning first we gotta sure yeah yeah
it doesn't work if you're not winning um
this is going to be a strange experience
for you tim duncan of the spurs
one of your all-time heroes growing up
you had his poster yeah
in your room and you idolize the guy and
then you play against him yeah in this
incredible series and win do you have
mixed feelings about that is it a
strange experience to play your hero
it's a strange experience at first um
first first of all you you can't believe
that you're here then you look across it
who you're playing and it's like man
this dude has way more experience than
me i don't know how i'm gonna fare out i
have to guard him and
you know it's uh it's gonna be a tough
experience but then you know you fast
forward we were in game seven i mean it
took me
actually like
looking back on it and saying wow i
can't believe that really just happened
like
who was your idol growing up uh andy
richter
no i growing up especially in this would
be for everybody like me is johnny
carson yeah so he's like all right you
know
you've got one show johnny carson's got
another show and you've got to do better
than him yeah actually you got to stop
johnny carson yeah
you know that does it that doesn't make
it it doesn't work it doesn't
it doesn't work the same way well you
know it does it yeah but i know what you
mean it would be like yeah but uh but i
understand what you're saying johnny
carson's been sent to murder you
you've got to stop that yeah and i've
got to stop him
this is a tv series